good morning John it's Friday
Valentine's Day that one day a year when
we come together to celebrate something
our culture is already unhealthily
obsessed with chocolate Valentine's Day
is third for chocolate consumption in
the United States after Halloween and
Easter on this day more than 50 million
tons of chocolate will be consumed Wow
not that I'm not gonna partake Catherine
and I are gonna be timtam slamming some
Bailey's Irish Cream while watching the
Olympics romantic one of those moments
when you realize being an adult is
actually pretty cool I mean I can suck
an aromatic liqueur into a chocolate
biscuit and fill it up within then eat
the whole anytime I want to you think
though I've been enjoying this some
people have that thing in their mind
that just lets them focus on one thing
for years so that they become the best
in the world at that one weird thing
it's a lot of sacrifice that you need to
make for exceptionalism and the weird
thing is why are these things valuable
anyway like what makes being good at
skiing and then shooting stuff any more
valuable than being really good at
flappy bird cultural agreement I guess
and where does that come from who cares
I don't care just like what a watch it
happened any three miles an hour down a
sheet of ice with sticks tied to your
feet I'm happy to watch this on a couch
while tanning slim slams some things I
think are just ridiculous like I no
offense but curling what is happening
this is weird but objectively I know
that it's no more weird than ice dancing
or hockey and shove off if you think
it's whether those are my two favorite
events hockey is basically just full
contact team ice dancing with sticks and
less awesome outfits for the events you
don't care that much about they have a
solution to that problem NBC just makes
these mini documentaries like a week ago
did I care about who Dina mazak was no
no I did but show me a mini documentary
about how she is both a pop star and a
world-class skier and has United
Slovenia under her winning smile
yes I will root for her then the Swiss
woman who had that terrible crash and
had to have nine surgeries on her knees
so that she could have one chance for
glory which one do I pick it doesn't
matter they was a tie for first I don't
care about this why am i crying
of course my objective scientists brain
is like there's no such thing as a tie
in a timed event if you go out to enough
significant figures
someone was faster here's a fascinating
thing they actually have more
significant figures than they show us so
someone knows somewhere which one of
those women actually win that event but
they are not allowed they sign a
contract that says this to tell us which
one was actually faster and I mean
really if you're that close you both
deserve the gold come on only problem
with the Olympics I don't want your
letter TV
and Wow commercials Wow every second
McDonald's is like hey did you enjoy
these extreme feats of athleticism try
out our 880 calorie chocolate-covered
strawberry Friday yeah you could
probably eat one of those if you were a
little gap elite because you burn like
8,000 calories a day the rest of us know
Tim Tam slamming Irish cream though
that's okay so Valentine's Day and enjoy
Olympic chocolate day ladies and Games
read a book hang out with the people you
love and don't let those world-class
athletes make you feel bad about sitting
on the couch with a plate full of
chocolate Jen I'll see you on Tuesday
Sarah I get open notice that we are
across the street from an Arby's your
art assignment find someone draw line
between the two you articulate something
intimate doing something you need a
thing to do and when it looks cool
you're done
now my post are subscribe to gunnarolla
his posters don't stick to walls where's
my tape where to put it
why did this happen to me I'm the good
person
here's a different thing a tape I'll
just let you know how stream Li
organised I am I'll do tanning Slim's
lambs